[Música]
a haití superó las 72 horas posteriores
al terremoto las consideradas horas
cruciales de cara a encontrar
supervivientes
esta ciudad los cayos es una de las más
afectadas por el seísmo del sábado en
esta región al suroeste del país se
estima que un 40 por ciento de la
población necesita de ayuda humanitaria
urgente a 200 kilómetros en carretera de
puerto príncipe de la capital de haití
los cayos se enfrentan a dificultades de
acceso por mal estado de las vías y
también a las organizaciones criminales
que dominan varias zonas en esta ruta
los medios locales reportan una tregua
con estas pandillas una buena noticia
que se suma a otra que llegó desde los
escombros 16 personas fueron rescatadas
el martes abriendo el camino de la
esperanza para un personal médico que
denuncia carencias
como este que no entiendo cómo los
helicópteros o los aviones pueden venir
a recoger pacientes llegan vacíos y se
van llenos pero cuando vienen podrían
traer medicamentos porque si no lo que
pasa es que tenemos que esperar durante
dos días 28 de cola bill jones un dato
el impacto sobre las viviendas fue tal
que campamentos como éste se van
llenando cada vez más de tiendas que se
han convertido en los nuevos hogares de
miles de damnificados
no tengo dinero no tengo casa todo lo
que tenía lo perdí no tengo dónde dormir
es la realidad de un pueblo que confía
en la llegada de una ayuda que les
permita sobrellevar esta nueva rutina
sin techo